son las 8 y 30 de la noche en bogotá
quito y lima continuamos en directo
américa edición nocturna seguimos
comentando lees los principales hechos
del día les agradecemos su sintonía y
vamos con los titulares de esta jornada
todo listo en colombia para la segunda
vuelta de las presidenciales que se
llevarán a cabo el domingo
observadores de 33 países acompañaran la
jornada según las autoridades
electorales sólo hasta el próximo
miércoles se conocerá oficialmente al
ganador de los comicios tenemos análisis
la comisión europea recomendó a ucrania
como candidata para ingresar al bloque
pero destacó que debe cumplir una serie
de condiciones para adaptarse a los
estándares europeos desde rusia vladimir
putin dijo que no se opone al ingreso
pues el bloque no es una organización
militar
europa se enfrenta a una ola de calor
que ha encendido las alarmas antes de
iniciar el verano reino unido francia y
españa están entre las naciones que han
registrado las altas temperaturas que se
espera continúen durante los próximos
días
[Aplausos]
[Música]
iniciamos en colombia donde las
autoridades ultiman detalles para la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales que se realizarán el
domingo 19 de junio
gustavo petro y rodolfo hernández se
miden ante más de 39 millones de
colombianos habilitados para votar en
más de 12.000 puestos tanto dentro del
país como en el exterior previamente
hablamos con carlos coronel ex
registrador delegado en lo electoral en
colombia y docente de la facultad de
derecho de la universidad javeriana que
nos explicó si hay confianza en el
sistema electoral colombiano luego de lo
ocurrido en las legislativas de marzo en
las que hubo irregularidades en el
conteo de votos con donde tengo una una
muy sólida tradición democrática como
tal en la conservación de sus
instituciones y también de la mano de un
excelente trabajo de un organismo
electoral que es de año 1990 es
independiente a las de rama del poder
público
es de todos conocimientos ha sido de
todos de público conocimiento las
dificultades importantes dudas en las
elecciones del congreso pero no obstante
lo anterior tal como se vio la primera
vuelta y estamos seguros que va a
demostrar la fortaleza de la señora
colombiana en este próximo domingo le
brindarán a todos los actores y a la
ciudadanía y al país y al mundo en
general una unas elecciones que estoy
seguro van a ser ejemplares donde se van
a ratificar vuelvo y repito la fortaleza
del sistema como tal independiente los
ajustes que tuvieron que hacerse para
dar un voto de confianza en este caso en
manos del árbitro que es el proceso
electoral ese sería un mensaje claro
desde la academia que lo observo así y
estoy seguro que así será
a ustedes los invitamos a este domingo a
conectarse con el especial que tendremos
preparado aquí en france 24 para la
segunda vuelta de las presidenciales
colombianas
andrés meza los estará acompañando con
el análisis de nuestros invitados y
periodistas en el lugar de la noticia de
las desde las 16 horas de bogotá quito y
lima
el presidente ecuatoriano guillermo
lasso hizo un nuevo llamado al diálogo
en el cuarto día de protestas indígenas
el mandatario pidió a los manifestantes
que frenen las movilizaciones y los
bloqueos por su parte el presidente de
la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas de ecuador conaie leonidas iza
anunció que marcharon hacia quitó en un
plazo máximo de 48 horas para continuar
con las manifestaciones contra el
encarecimiento de los productos y otras
políticas del ejecutivo
hemos insistido en nuestra disposición
al diálogo
varias organizaciones se han ofrecido a
mediar la iglesia naciones unidas- y
universidades bienvenidos todos ellos
estamos listos a impedir que las
movilizaciones se vuelvan más violentas
a utilizar dentro del marco de la ley el
uso progresivo de la fuerza cambiamos la
información y vamos a ucrania la
comisión europea recomendó otorgar a
este país el estatus de candidato a la
unión europea se trata de un primer paso
en un largo proceso para que esta nación
pueda convertirse en miembro oficial del
bloque comunitario la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula von der leyen
hizo el anuncio alegando que los
ucranianos están dispuestos a morir por
el sueño europeo los detalles desde
bruselas con nuestra corresponsal esther
herrera
moldavia y ucrania han agradecido a la
comisión europea al reconocimiento de
ser países candidatos a la unión europea
para el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski este es un gran paso para
acercar al país hacia la victoria
georgiano ha conseguido el estatus de
candidato porque antes la comisión
europea le pide que hagas reformas aún
así el país considera que es un camino
para poder acercarles a la unión europea
se trata de un apoyo moral para los
países pero sobre todo para ucrania que
pidió el estatus de candidato hizo
oficial su candidatura a tan sólo cuatro
días después de que estallara la guerra
eso sí la comisión europea lo deja muy
claro los dos países tanto moldavia como
ucrania tendrán que cumplir una serie de
condiciones como la reforma del estado
de derecho a la independencia judicial y
también la lucha contra la corrupción si
quieren mantener este estatus de
candidato porque la comisión europea
insiste en que el proceso es reversible
y que vigilará muy de cerca las reformas
de techo a finales de este año se va a
hacer una evaluación para comprobar si
real están yendo por el buen camino tras
esta recomendación de la comisión
europea los líderes europeos tendrán que
darle el visto bueno algo que se espera
que se pueda producir en una reunión de
líderes europeos la semana que viene aún
así esto no significa que empiece ya el
proceso de negociación hacia la unión
europea es un proceso muy largo en que
no hay tiempos límite y que de hecho es
muy complejo porque hay que negociar
hasta 35 capítulos de negociación
pasando desde la educación hasta la
economía un proceso que puede tardar
muchos años incluso el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón dijo que podría
durar hasta 20 años en el marco del foro
económico de san petersburgo el
presidente ruso vladimir putin aprovechó
el evento para recalcar la postura de su
país frente a la invasión a ucrania que
a ojos de moscú corresponde a una
operación militar especial que le ha
traído rechazo y un cerco económico y
político a su país con serias
repercusiones y extingue minibuses por
cierto no tengo ninguna duda de que
pasará el tiempo y muchos de nuestros
socios de algunos países europeos
volverán al mercado ruso eran felices
aquí así se refirió a la vecina europa
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin al
intervenir en el vigésimo quinto foro
económico de san petersburgo en el
encuentro señaló las sanciones de
washington y el bloque europeo contra
los fertilizantes rusos como las
culpables de la actual crisis
alimentaria en este sentido el
mandatario acusó a bruselas de haber
perdido su soberanía política causando
daños a sus propios ciudadanos y
negocios
putin se refirió además a las relaciones
con ucrania al término de la invasión
de la población ucraniana tiene talento
durante nos basamos en la idea de que
tarde o temprano la situación volverá a
la normalidad
nos interesa que todos nuestros vecinos
prosperen entonces es inevitable mis
quiero ser claros el restablecimiento de
las religiones es inhibir las personas
de boston avileña sin embargo quien
mantiene su mirada al oeste este viernes
el presidente ucraniano recibió por
segunda vez desde el inicio del
conflicto al primer ministro del reino
unido- porción son la reunión entre
ambos trató temas claves como él y listo
de armas y el entrenamiento de las
fuerzas ucranianas por parte del hombre
estamos aquí nuevamente para subrayar
que estamos aquí con usted para brindar
de la resistencia estratégica que
necesitará y continuaremos ayudando a
intensificar las sanciones contra el
régimen de putting out wiggins grade hoy
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen recomendó que se le
otorgue a ucrania el estatus de
candidatos para formar parte de la unión
al menos una persona murió este viernes
y varias resultaron heridas en una nueva
jornada de protestas en india contra una
polémica reforma en el ejército según la
cual tras un período de prueba de cuatro
años sólo el 25 por ciento de los
jóvenes podrían continuar en actividad
el gobierno de narendra modi está
presionando para aumentar los puestos de
trabajo a medida que la economía india
se recupera de la pandemia
las protestas en la india se
intensifican contra un nuevo proceso de
reclutamiento militar al acceso a las
fuerzas armadas es la última esperanza
de miles de jóvenes para obtener una
fuente de ingreso pero esta medida
genera incertidumbre entre los
aspirantes al ejército solo puede
reclutar 46 miles de personas entre 17 y
21 años para 4 años y el 75% de ellos se
jubilarán obligatoriamente al fin de
este periodo sin ninguna prestación
los jóvenes sueñan con alistarse en el
ejército pero este nuevo sistema
contractual ha supuesto un gran revés
para los jóvenes así que ahora la
demanda es que el gobierno detenga a
esta dictadura y no introduzca un
sistema contractual en el ejército
siete estados indios registraron brotes
de violencia durante las protestas
dejando un muerto y varios heridos los
jóvenes dañaron numerosas propiedades e
incendiaron vagones de tren
interrumpiendo los servicios en la
región durante varias horas
los daños a las propiedades públicas
están causando pérdidas millonarias si
los manifestantes se habían manifestado
pacíficamente habría sido aceptable pero
la violencia no ayuda a nadie a los
partidos de la oposición y algunos
miembros del partido de moody han
criticado la reforma diciendo que el
sistema conducirá más desempleo en el
país que ya se encuentra en una tasa del
7.5 por ciento según el centro para el
seguimiento de la economía india en
vista de las críticas el ministro de
defensa de la india anunció este viernes
que aumentará dicho límite de edad para
aceptar el ingreso de jóvenes de hasta
23 años
este viernes una nueva redada militar
israelí dejó tres palestinos muertos en
un campamento de jenín en la cisjordania
ocupada operativos de este tipo se han
hecho más frecuentes en los últimos
meses en respuesta a los recientes
ataques terroristas en israel ampliamos
en el siguiente informe
de bala
[Aplausos]
cientos de residentes iracundos cantan
dios es grande y piden venganza mientras
cargan los cadáveres de tres hombres que
murieron a manos del ejército israelí en
la madrugada del viernes es un crimen
enorme podría haber evitado matarlos
podrían haber disparado a las ruedas del
coche esto es un crimen dios es grande
que dios los bendiga mucho otras
personas resultaron heridas las fuerzas
israelíes dicen que los tres hombres que
iban en este coche ahora acribillado
abrieron fuego y ellos respondieron con
munición real
[Música]
las tropas de golán y en varias unidades
patrullaban por la amplitud de jenín en
otra noche de detenciones
una de las unidades divisó un vehículo
sospechoso lo que generó un
enfrentamiento en el que los mandos
lideraron desde el frente o volar sólo
factible fermín
recurso y se mostró un escuadrón
terrorista vivo el ejército israelí
lleva a cabo frecuentes incursiones
nocturnas en jenín y otras partes de
cisjordania después de una serie de
ataques terroristas mortales en israel
la que mató a 19 personas en los últimos
dos meses las autoridades palestinas
sostienen que en el mismo período han
muerto 30 personas en territorio ocupado
esta es también la región donde la
periodista de al yazira sirena bucle fue
asesinada a tiros el mes pasado mientras
cubría una operación del ejército
israelí las conversaciones de paz entre
israelíes y palestinos están congeladas
desde hace años y los recientes
atentados contra ambas partes reavivan
aún más las tensiones europa de una
intensa ola de calor y las playas se
convirtieron en un sitio infalible para
mitigar las altas temperaturas mientras
que la sombra en los parques y las
fuentes son muy codiciadas en españa el
riesgo de incendios forestales es
extremo en casi todo el país el informe
es de rafael pérez
sombra hidratación y poca ropa son los
remedios que los europeos se encuentran
en medio de la ola de calor que afecta
al viejo continente en el reino unido
los termómetros marcaron el día más
cálido del año hasta ahora con 34 grados
centígrados allí y centenares de
personas salieron a las playas para
mitigar los efectos de las altas
temperaturas
nacionales y turistas son conscientes de
las causas de ese fenómeno meteorológico
está lloviendo y estoy en londres y
estoy sirviendo aquí así que algo debe
cambiar necesitamos tomar precauciones
sobre el cambio climático más temprano
que tarde porque sin duda es preocupante
para todos nosotros ahora lo estamos
disfrutando pero a largo plazo podríamos
sacrificarnos por un turn micro limits a
qué país en francia se vive en
temperaturas récord en burdeos los 39
grados reinantes hacen que las sombras y
las fuentes adquieran un valor
incalculable los parques albergan
personas semidesnudas que disfrutan de
la frescura de esos sitios
y durante el día voy a los museos a los
jardines a todos los centros comerciales
cualquier cosa para refrescar mis ideas
y me tomo mi tiempo para no pasar
demasiado calor pero por la noche donde
estoy es bajo techo y es insoportable
en españa las temperaturas han alcanzado
los 43 grados lo que hace que aumente el
riesgo de incendios forestales
cataluña ha perdido más de 500 hectáreas
de bosque producto de las llamas cerca
de baldomar en casi todo el país el
riesgo de fuego es extremo según la
agencia estatal de metereología así
llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo americano a ustedes les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros que ya llega
maría clara calle con toda la
información del continente americano en
aquí américa feliz noche para todos
[Música]